hey what's up guys it's Pedro here from
new cutter calm and in this tutorial
were to learn how to install nodejs
as well as learn how to actually run
code using node.js
so to get started we're gonna actually
have to download node.js so if you go to
google and type nodejs download you
should get a web page similar to this
and i will be leaving a link in the
description in case you can't find it so
go ahead and download eight point eleven
point three
LTS now once you download that run it
install it enjoy all that good stuff and
within these tutorials i'm gonna be
using Visual Studio code and if you
don't know what Visual Studio code is
it's an editor now you can use whatever
editor you want but the reason I'm using
Visual Studio code is because it has an
integrated command prompt so once you
download these two things I'm just gonna
head over to my desktop and let's create
a new folder and I'm just going to say
no js' tutorial and now I'm just gonna
head over to Visual Studio code and you
should have a welcome screen like this
go to file open folder and we are gonna
open the folder that we just created so
I'm just gonna select this and now I'm
just gonna hit ctrl n ctrl n is gonna
create a new file I'm gonna hit ctrl s
and we are going to save this file and
I'm just gonna say app dot J s and this
is going to be a very very simplistic
javascript file and we are just gonna
run it and this is just the test to see
if you installed node.js correctly so if
I hit console.log hello world from
nodejs now if I save this and I'm
actually going to exit out of this but
you saw that this just popped up on my
screen if I go to terminal here
our command prompt so I'm just gonna
exit this to show you how you could
bring this up whenever you want to run a
code using the terminal so I'm just
gonna close this I'm gonna hit control B
I am going to go to view I'm gonna go to
integrated terminal now by default
Visual Studio code has it on power show
so if I go up here you can notice that
mine says C on D so if I hit control
shift P and type default I can say
select default show now I have three
terminals installed on my computer you
probably have PowerShell and you
probably have command prompt and I also
have git go ahead and click command
prompt hit this plus button this is
going to bring up a new terminal so if I
was to hit this will bring up another
CMD and this should say CMD so I'm just
gonna remove for me I'm gonna remove one
since I already have one open and now
all I'm gonna do is type node and then
the name of the file so the name of the
file that we just created what's called
a pas and here we go we get an output of
hello world from nodejs now let's say
that you're not using Visual Studio code
for whatever reason you have your own
editor of choice what you can do is you
hit the Start menu type CMD and then go
to command prompt and then you can see
that we get something very similar to
the integrated command prompt but we're
in a different location so if I go to my
desktop open this folder let's copy the
path that this folder is located so I'm
just gonna hit ctrl C to copy head over
to my command prompt
I'm just gonna type CD CD stands for
change directory all that means is hey
change folder so right now I am in a
folder called users Pedro Mikado I need
to be in this folder so now I'm just
gonna click this go down to edit click
paste and that's our path so now if I
hit enter you can see that our path has
changed and now if I type node app dot J
yes you can see that we get a hello
world from node so either way is fine if
you want to use Visual Studio code and
it's integrated terminal you're more
than welcome to if you're using a
different editor and it doesn't have its
own integrated terminal you're more than
welcome to use the command prompt
in this tutorial we're gonna be talking
about node modules all a node module is
is basically a JavaScript file it's a
way to separate concerns for our
application so for example let's say
that I have an app dot J's file and in
this app dot J's file I have math a
bunch of API requests and database calls
instead of putting them all in one file
what we can do is separate each of those
concerns into their own files so to get
started I'm just gonna hit ctrl B I'm
gonna say ctrl n so we're gonna create a
new file and I'm just going to say ctrl
s and we're gonna save it as the toriel
dot J yes let's save that control B and
now we can focus on this new file or
this new module called Satori ojs so to
get started let's actually give our
tutorial module something so I'm gonna
give it a function so I'm gonna say
consum and it's gonna have two
parameters and all its gonna do is add
and return them so num1 plus num2 next
what I want to end up doing is I want to
expose this function to the outside
world because right now if I hit control
s and if I was to try to use this
function so I'm just going to delete
this so if I was just to say sum 1 plus
1 and if we were to actually run this
you can see that we get an error sum is
not defined so you might be saying why
is some not defined I just defined it
here well I need to expose this function
for the outside world to use so I need
to let know know that this sum function
within my tutorial module is available
to be used so in order to do that all I
need to do is type module export and
pass it in some like so
now that this is available to be used I
need to tell my app.js file where this
sum function is located so what I can do
here is the clear variable so I'm just
gonna say Kant's tutorial and now I'm
just going to use the word require and
then we're gonna give it a path now the
path is dot forward slash so where did I
get dot forward slash firm dot forward
slash means that it's within the same
exact path that this file is currently
in where app dot J yes so if I was to
hit ctrl B you can see that I dot J s is
on the same level as tutorial dot J s
and that they're in the same folder
called nodejs
tutorial so if I hit control V again get
rid of that and then I pass in the name
of the file which is obviously tutorial
j s now you do not need to pass in the
extension all you need to do is pass in
the name of the file no js'
automatically assumes that it is a
JavaScript file and now if I was to
print out tutorial so let's see what's
inside it and now let's get rid of our
son call we're gonna cost some a little
bit later I just want to show you what
the variable tutorial has so if I was to
save this and let's scroll down I'm
gonna type CLS hit enter that's gonna
clear the terminal and now I'm just
gonna run node app and you can see that
the toriel now holds a function called
sum from our tutorial module so now if I
want to actually use that function I can
say tutorial and pass in 1+1 and let's
actually print out the result so I'm
just gonna say console dot log it let's
save it execute it again and you can see
that we get our desired output of two
and that we are indeed
porting from our tutorial module the sum
function so now that we know how to do
that how would we import multiple stuff
from modules so for example if we head
back to our tutorial module let's say I
have multiple functions or multiple
variables or even a class how do I
export more than one thing well what you
can do is I can say and just for the
sake of example let's add more stuff so
I could say cons PI and I'm just gonna
set this to 3.14 and let's create a
class and I'm gonna say some math object
let's give it a constructor and I'm just
gonna say object create it okay so now I
have some pie and some math object now I
want all three of these to be exposed to
the outside world
so that app that J yes for example can
require them and then use it so how do I
do that well one way to do that is to
add properties to the module exports
object so for example I could say dot
some and I'm just going to copy this so
now exports dot some is going to have
the sum function exports dot pi is going
to hold the value of 3.14 so I just set
it equal to PI and some math object it's
gonna be module data exports dot some
math object is gonna be equal to some
math object now if I was to save this
head over to app and let's just remove
this for now I want to print out what
tutorial is holding once we require from
our tutorial module so if I save this
and now let's execute this
you can see that we're getting an object
back tutorial is now an object and now
this object has the properties of some
and it tells you that it's a function pi
the value of pi and some math object and
you can see that it's our class and now
if I want to execute this it'll be like
accessing a normal object so for example
we have tutorial and let's say we want
to use the sum function instead of just
saying tutorial and then passing the two
numbers I guess a tutorial some and pass
in the two numbers and I'm just gonna
copy this let's paste this two more
times and now if I want to print pi I
could say tutorial PI and within here
the same thing for the object I could
say new tutorial dot some math object
and that's going to create a new
instance of our some math object and now
if I was to save this and run it you can
see that it executes as expected so
tutorial sum gives us two pi has the
value of 3.14 and you can see that our
constructor gets executed object created
one more thing to show you before I wrap
this up if this is an ugly syntax for
you for example saying module dot
exports that sum equals this module de
exports dot pi is a bit repetitive what
we can do is instead of exporting each
of these individually I'm going to let's
remove two of them and instead what we
can do is export an object at literal
and tag along the properties so I can
say sum is going to be some pie
is it going to be pie and then some math
object is going to be some math object
and if I'm to save this and now execute
it we should get the same exact result
let's execute that you can see that it's
working beautifully
in this tutorial
talking about the events module
particularly the events emitter class
within the events module now all the
events module allows us to do is
basically bring event-driven programming
to no js' so to get started we're going
to actually have to require the events
module now the events module is actually
built into nodejs so I'm just going to
say Kahn's event emitter now this is
going to be the class that we get from
requiring from the event module and I'm
just going to say equal require event
now from here we're going to have to
create a new instance of the event
emitter so I'm just going to say Const
event emitter and as a new event emitter
so from here we're going to start
getting into event-driven programming
now that I have my event emitter object
let's actually attach a listener to it
so I'm just going to say event emitter
and I'm going to call the method on now
this method takes on two arguments one
is the listener that you want to attach
to this object so I'm just going to call
it tutorial for this example and the
second argument is going to be the
function that you want to execute when
this tutorial event occurs so let's just
pass in this function and all I'm going
to say is console dot log tutorial event
has occurred so now if I save this and
run it so I'm just going to hit ctrl as
the save and I'm just going to say node
app you can see that nothing happens
within our terminal now why is that well
I have this object I've attached a
listener called tutorial but I haven't
emitted a tutorial event remember this
code here is
only going to be executed when a
tutorial event occurs
so now let's emit a tutorial event so
I'm just going to say event emitter and
now I'm just going to pass in tutorial
as the first argument and that's it so
now if I was to hit ctrl s to save and
now execute this one more time you can
see that our tutorial event gets
triggered whenever we call the emit
method so now what happens when we
actually want this function to have
parameters well I could give it
parameters so I could say num1 num2 and
just for argument's sake so just a show
on the console we're gonna print out the
sum of num1 and num2 so now how would I
call it down here with the emit method
well I'll just pass it in as an argument
so I could pass in one and two so if I
save this now and now go to node app you
can see that we get the value of three
so you just pass in the arguments now
this is all fine and dandy but how would
I create a custom object which takes
advantage of using events well I could
just inherit from the event emitter
class so for example let's say that I
want to create a person class I say
class person and I could just extend
from the event emitter class and now
from here let's give it a constructor
now let's call our super function so I'm
just gonna say super and this is going
to allow us to use the disk property
within our class and now I'm just going
to save this that underscore name is
going to be assigned value of name and
now let's actually pass in name to our
constructor and now let's give this
person class a getter so I'm just going
to say get
and all this is gonna do is just return
this dot underscore name so now that we
have our person class defined let's
actually create a new instance of it so
I'm just going to go down here and I'm
just going to say let Pedro equal new
person and let's pass in Pedro and now
here remember when I say new person
person extends the event emitter class
which means that Pedro is also an
instance of the event emitter class
so now I can add a listener to the pager
object so I could just say Pedro dot on
and I'm just going to call it name and
we're going to pass in our function and
I'm just going to print out my name is
so-and-so so I'm just going to say
console dot log my name is and we're
just going to say Pedro dot name
so now that we've attached our listener
obviously we're going to have to call
the Amit method so we're going to omit
the event has occurred so I'm just gonna
say Pedro that Amit and we're gonna pass
in name and now if I was to save this
and now execute this you can see that we
get the desired output of my name is
Pedro so that's how you would extend
using the event emitters class and for
our final example let's say that we have
more than one person object so I'm just
going to create a new person I'm just
gonna call let's make it a girl I'm just
gonna call her Christina I'm gonna say
new person and we're gonna pass in
Christina now let's add a listener to
the Christina object so I'm just gonna
say Christine on that on name and you
could use a loop for this but since I'm
only creating two person objects it
doesn't make sense for this example but
you can use a loop to do this on one
shot and we are just going to copy this
base this in here and I'm just gonna say
Christina dot name alright so why did I
go through the bother of showing you
that we created two person objects and
attached listeners to it well what I
want to show you is that when you emit
an event to occur the event gets
executed synchronously so for example if
I say Pedro and I say Christina and now
if I was to save this and now execute it
you can see that that these get executed
synchronously
so because Pedro emitted first Pedro
gets executed first and then our
Christina object so they get executed in
the order that they admit it in so they
execute synchronously
and this tutorial
talking about the read line mod rule now
what the redline module allows us to do
is prompt the user as well as get user
input so to get started we're going to
have to require the module so I'm just
going to say cons read line is equal to
require read line and this is going to
bring in our redline module next we're
going to have to create an instance of
the read line interface by using the
create interface method so I'm just
going to say read line dot create
interface and within here is going to
take an object now we're going to give
this object two properties and this is
basically our configuration file so the
first property I'm going to give it is
input and then we're going to give it an
object now this object is called process
now process is a global object so you
don't have to require it it's already
given to us by node and then here we're
going to say STD in now input is going
to be the STD in input screen and then
here we obviously need an output so I'm
just going to say output and we're going
to give it process that STD out and
that's going to stand for output stream
now when this method is executed is
going to return our read line interface
object so let's save it inside a
variable so we can use it so I'm just
gonna say Const RL is equal to this now
let's say I want to ask the user what
two numbers added together are equal to
so for this example I'm just gonna
generate two random numbers between 1
and 10 so I'm just going to say it will
let num1 equal math dot floor math dot
random
and we're going to ties this fight 10
and we're going to shift it over by one
so this is going to give us a random
number between 1 and 10 let's copy this
twice paste it to and we need the answer
so I'm just gonna say let answer equal
number one plus num2 alright so now that
we have this we're ready to ask the user
what these two numbers are equal to now
in order to do that I'm gonna use our
red line interface and our red line
interface has a method called question
so I'm gonna say RL question now the
first argument is going to be a string
the second argument is going to be a
function and basically the first
argument is going to be the question we
would like to ask the user so I'm just
gonna say back tick what is num1 plus
num2 question mark and I'm just gonna
hit enter here because I want you guys
to see this on one line and we're going
to include our call back now this
function is going to get the user input
as a parameter so I'm just gonna say
user input and for now I'm just gonna
print out user input onto the console
just so you guys can see that it's
actually working so now if I was to save
this head over to my console type node
app it's going to say what is 4 plus 2
I'm gonna say banana and there you go it
prints out the users input it's
important to note that if you take a
look at our console the application is
still running so I'm just gonna hit ctrl
C to break out of it and what we need to
do is actually close the red line
interface when we're done
using it so in order to do that
that's actually add a couple things
first thing I want a new line right
after this question mark here so I'm
just gonna say forward slash then so
when I prompt the user the users input
instead of lining up right next to it
like so it's gonna be underneath all
right so I fixed that problem next thing
I want to do is actually test the user
input to see if he actually got the
answer correct so in order to do that
I'm just going to say if user input and
it's always important to trim the user's
input if you ever accept anything from a
user just to get rid of the trailing
whitespace and we're just going to say
if the users input is equal to answer so
if they answer the math question
correctly I want to close the
application so I could say RL dot close
and here and now if I was to save this
and now execute the program so I'm just
gonna write node app is going to say
what is 10 plus 4 and I'm going to
answer with 14 and you can see that we
answered it correctly and therefore our
application closed now what I want to do
is actually add a listener to the closed
event now the red line interface is
actually an instance of the event
emitter class so what we can do is
actually scroll down here and I'll add
it up towards the end and I want to say
our own dot on and basically I'm going
to say hey I want you to listen for an
event to occur and I'm going to say
close and we're gonna give it a callback
and this function is only going to
execute when we close the reline
interface so now I'm just gonna say
console dot log and basically I just
want to let the user know that hey you
got the correct answer so I'm just gonna
say correct
so now if I was to save this and now
execute it note app what is six plus
three I'm just going to write nine you
can see that correct gets printed out on
to the console now correct gets printed
out on to the console because when we
use the method close it omits the close
event and since we're listening for a
closed event this callback function gets
executed and on that note I better add a
semicolon on there and let's save that
so now that we handled what happens when
the user inputs correctly what happens
if the user gets the wrong answer so in
order to do that let's create an else
statement within our question method
here so I'm just going to say else and
what I want to do basically is reap romp
the user so I'm just going to say our l
dot prompt dot set prompt and set prompt
is basically going to take an argument
of string and it's going to ask the user
basically what you want to know so I'm
going to say to the user incorrect
response please try again and let's add
a new line here and now in order to use
the prompt I actually have to call it so
the first method is to set the prompt
the second method is gonna be to call it
so I'm just gonna say our l prompt so
now I'm just going to hit ctrl s to save
and now I'm just going to execute this
no wood app and it's gonna say what is 1
+ 5 and I'm going to say banana and it's
gonna say incorrect response please try
again now I actually haven't told it
what to do once the user inputs so let's
actually write the code for that now and
what I'm going to do is actually add a
listener to our red line interface so
I'm going to listen for the users input
and the event for that is our o dot on
line and then we're going to pass it in
a callback
now this callback is going to have the
users input and now we're going to
decide what to do once we get the users
input so obviously what we want to do is
check if the users input is correct and
if it is correct we are going to close
the application and now what happens if
it isn't correct
we're going to say else and then I'm
gonna reset the prompt so I'm just gonna
say RL dot set drop and I'm gonna say
let's actually make this more
informative so I'm just gonna say your
answer of and then we're just going to
print out what they wrote user input is
incorrect and we're gonna do a forward
slash and before that I'm just going to
say try again so now let's end that and
now we remember once we set the prompt
we actually have to call it so now I'm
just going to say our l dot prompt and
now if we just take a look at what we
have so far this is basically going to
give us a loop so we set a line event
listener now when the user enters input
that's going to trigger this line input
we're gonna test the see of what he gave
us is correct and if it is we're just
going to close the application and if we
close the application this on close
method is going to execute it's going to
say correct
so now let's see what happens if we give
it the wrong value is going to execute
the else statement it's gonna set the
prompt your answer of so-and-so is wrong
and then is going to prompt the user
again and basically this line event is
going to keep executing until the user
enters the correct input so let's
actually take a look at this in action
so I'm just going to clear the terminal
and before I execute let me just say
ctrl s to save
oops ctrl s to save and now I'm just
going to hit node app and it's going to
say what is 1 plus 4 I'm going to say
banana incorrect response please try
again I'm going to type banana again
your answer banana is not correct and
you can see that this will go on
indefinitely now if I go back up and
let's actually see what it was what is 1
plus 4 I'm just going to type in 5 and
you can see we get the output of correct
and then it exits the application
and in this tutorial we're gonna be
talking about the file system module now
what the file system module allows us to
do is work with the file system and what
I mean by that is that it allows us to
create files read files delete files
create folders stuff like that
so to get started we're gonna have to
require the file module into our project
so I'm just gonna set cons FS is equal
to require FS so now that we have the
filesystem module within our node
application let's actually use it now if
I hit ctrl B you can see that all I have
is my app dot jes file within my node.js
tutorials folder so let's actually
create a file so this one's going to
create a file and we're gonna say FS dot
right file now the first argument is
going to be the name of the file so I'm
just going to say example dot txt the
second argument is what you want to
write to the file so I'm just going to
say this is an example and the third
argument is going to be a callback and
this callback is going to have a
parameter of error in case anything goes
wrong so I'm just gonna say err
[Music]
and there we go
so let's actually finish writing this so
I could say if error we're just going to
print out the error otherwise we can say
file successfully created so I'm just
gonna write file successfully create it
so now if I was to save this and let's
run
a node app you can see that we get files
successfully created and now if I hit
control B it's good not to be in the
console when I do that control B now you
can see that we have a newly created
file called example txt and if we look
in it we see the data that we wrote to
the file now that we created this file
that's actually read it let's open it up
and read it so if I was to say control B
again and I'm just gonna go to app by
J's and within this else statement let's
put all this code within here and now
I'm gonna say FS about read file and
within here the first argument much like
the right file method is going to be the
name of the file that you want to read
so I'm just gonna say example dot txt
the second argument is going to be the
encoding type now I'm gonna leave this
blank because I want to show you guys
what happens when you don't leave an
encoding type and then the third
argument is going to take a callback
function and this callback function has
two parameters it has error and it has
the file that you actually want to read
now in here I actually want to show you
guys what the file looks like so we're
going to do the same thing that we did
in the right file method I'm going to
check if there's any errors and if there
are no errors
I just want to print the file itself
now if I was to save this or the node
app now you see that the file was
successfully created and then you see
that when we print out the file we get
this buffer stream and then we get this
bunch of numbers following it now the
buffer stream stores data in binary okay
so what we need to do is specify the
encoding type that we want it to be
displayed as so up here we're gonna go
up here and I'm just gonna pass in utf-8
so that's the encoding that I want and
now if I was to save this go to node app
you can see that file was successfully
created
and we're successfully reading the
contents within the file alright so now
that we know how to create and read
files let's actually cover a few more
methods so what I want to do is start
with a fresh example so I'm just gonna
comment this all out I'm just gonna
highlight everything ctrl backslash and
that's going to comment everything out
for me now what I want to do is let's
say that when I created this example dot
txt file that I really didn't mean to
call it example dot txt let's say I
wanted to call it example 2 for instance
well I could use the rename method so I
could do something like this I can say F
s dot rename and rename is going to take
in three arguments the first argument is
going to be example dot txt and that's
going to be the name of the file that we
want to rename the second argument is
going to be what we want to rename the
file to so I'm just gonna say example
two dot txt and the third argument is
going to be the callback function which
has a parameter called error and we're
gonna do the same
as we've been doing for all these
asynchronous calls we're just going to
say if error we're just going to print
that out to the console if there's no
error and everything went fine we're
going to say successfully renamed the
file so I'm just gonna say successfully
renamed the file so now if I hit ctrl s
to save and now let's run this you can
see successfully renamed the file and it
says deleted from this and that's
probably because it hasn't updated yet
so if I close this and I'm just gonna
hit control B and you can see that
within our package Explorer that our
file has been renamed to example 2 dot
txt and if I open this is the same exact
file of that recreated a couple of more
methods that I want to go over so I'm
just gonna hit ctrl B and let's say that
once I comment this out let's say that
when I was creating the file that I
forgot to add something towards the end
of the file so what do you want to do I
want to append data to the file so I'm
just gonna say FS dot append file it's
going to take in three arguments it's
going to take in the name of the files
so I'm just going to say example two dot
txt the second argument is going to be
the data that you want to append to the
file so I'm just gonna say some data
being upended and the third argument is
going to be the callback function and
this is going to have an error as a
parameter pass this in and we're going
to say if error print it out to the
console
we're gonna print out that the
successfully appended data to the file
so successfully appended data to file
I'm just gonna move this over so you can
see and now if I save this and execute
this so node app you'll see successfully
appended data to the file so let's
actually take a look at our file and you
can see that our file has been changed
so before we had this as an example and
then we append it's on data to the end
of the file in the last method that I
want to cover within this tutorial is
how do I delete a file so for example we
did all this and let's say that I've had
enough with this file I just want it
gone so let's just comment this out and
this is gonna be the final method that I
go over so we're just going to say F s
dot unlink and the first argument is
obviously you guys should get this by
now it's going to be example to example
two dot txt and the second argument is
going to be a callback function and have
the parameter of error and within here
if error print it out to the console if
there's nowhere where we're just going
to say successfully delete it the file
successfully so now if I was to save
this and now execute it you can see
successfully deleted the file so this up
here deleted from this so if I closed
this and if I was to hit control B to
bring up the package Explorer you can
see that the file no longer exists
in this tutorial is going to be part 2
of my file system modules tutorial now
in the previous tutorial we went over
using the file system module to work
with files and this I want to go over
how to work with folders so to get
started we're gonna have to require the
file system module so I'm just gonna say
Const FS equal require and then FS here
all right now what I want to do is I'm
going to say FS dot M K dur and what MK
dur stands for is make directory and all
directory is is a folder so now here is
going to take in a two arguments one is
going to be the folder name that you
want so I'm gonna give it the value of
tutorial and then we're gonna pass in
the callback with an error and we're
just going to say if error console dot
log two error Ellis we successfully
created the folder Sonya so say
console.log folder successfully created
so now if I was to save this and now
before I actually run this I'm just
gonna hit ctrl B so you don't see that
there's any magic happening so all I
have is my nodejs tutorial folder and an
app dot J's file so now if I go here
type node app you can see that we get
the output of folder successfully
created and that our tutorials folder
has been created now let's say that I
actually want to delete this folder so
I'm just gonna hit ctrl B again and this
is actually going to give us an error
but I'm just going to show you what the
error is is basically going to complain
that this folder it really exists so I'm
just gonna say FS dot R M and aren't M
stands for remove and then dur and that
stands for remove folder now I'm going
to give the folder name so we called it
tutorial and this is also going to
take a callback which gets an error so
now if I say if error console dot log at
the error else we're gonna say
successfully deleted the folder
successfully delete it the folder so now
if I was to save this and now execute it
you see that we get an error file
already exists and that's because the
tutorials folder already exists and
we're trying to create another folder
name the same thing so I'm just gonna
hit ctrl B we're gonna delete the
tutorial folder so I'm just gonna hit
delete confirm that ctrl V again let's
execute this and you can see that we
successfully deleted the folder so if I
go up here hit ctrl B you see that it
doesn't exist so first thing we do is we
create a folder called tutorial and then
if this is successful then we're gonna
delete the folder called tutorial and
you can see by the output that we
successfully deleted the folder now this
is too fast and that's why you wouldn't
be able to see it if we had the package
manager open so now that we know how to
create and delete a folder what I want
to do now is create a folder and then
create a file within that folder so I'm
just gonna hit ctrl B and we can leave
this make directory so we're gonna make
a folder called tutorial and if it's
successful it's going to execute this
else block so let's remove this and then
within here we're gonna create our new
file so to do that I'm just going to say
FS the right file now right file is
going to take in three arguments
it's gonna take in the name of the fire
but in this case we got to give it the
full path so I'm gonna say dot for a
slash and what da for slash means is I
want you to start relative to AB dot J s
and then I want you to go inside the
folder call it tutorial so I'm just
gonna hit ctrl B just to show you so app
dot j s starts here there's going to be
a folder called tutorial so I'm going to
go inside that folder tutorial and now I
want to you to create the file called
example dot txt so if I hit ctrl V again
and then the second argument is going to
be what the data that you want I'm just
going to write one two three doesn't
matter for this example and then the
third argument is it going to be a
callback function which gets an error
and then within here I'm going to write
if error console dot log two error on to
the console else we're gonna write
successfully create it file successfully
created file so now let's save this so
I'm just gonna hit ctrl s go down here
note app and you can see that it says
successfully created file down here so
now if I hit ctrl B and I'm gonna go up
here and then hit control B you can see
that we have our newly created tutorial
folder and within here we have our
example dot txt so if we go in here you
can see it has the data of one two and
three now what I want to show you is how
would I delete a folder that has a file
within it
so you might be saying if I just go back
here hit control B that can't I just use
F s dot remove directory in order to do
this well I am actually just going to
comment on
so and what will end up happening if I
use the remove directory function is
that is that I'll get an error and the
reason for that is because if I use the
remove directory function it has to be
used on a directory or folder that is
empty so just to show Ella straight this
just going to write this quick remove
directory function and if there's an
error print it else we're just gonna
print delete it folder so I'm just gonna
hit ctrl s to save and I'm just gonna
tie cos the clear to terminal node app
and you can see that we get an error
directory not empty that we're trying to
remove a directory that has a file
within it so in order to fix that let's
delete the file first so I'm just gonna
say F s dot unlink and the first
argument is going to be the file
so remember dot forward slash and then
we have to go into the tutorials folder
and then I name the file example dot txt
next argument is going to be a callback
function which has an error and I'm just
gonna say if error print it out if
there's no error then what I want to do
well if there's no error that means that
I successfully to delete the file which
means I can now successfully remove the
file so I'm just going to copy this and
I'm gonna put this within the else block
here I add some semicolons
and now if I was to save this and now
execute it you can see that we have
deleted folder and you can see up here
delete it from disk so if I go hit ctrl
B you can see that the folders been
successfully deleted so what did we do
first we deleted the file that was
within the folder and then if that was
successful then I wanted to delete the
folder itself last example that I want
to do is what happens when there are
multiple files within a folder and you
want to delete all those files so I'm
gonna cheat a little bit and we're just
gonna create it within our package
explorer so I'm just gonna say new
folder and we're gonna call it example
and I'm just going to give it two files
so I'm just gonna say a dot txt and the
second file is going to be me dot txt
all right so now I have my folder and I
have my two files so how would I go
about doing this well there's a method
called read directory and what read
directory does is it gives you back the
list of files that you have within that
folder so let's actually call it so I'm
just gonna comment on this out comment
this out and then I'm just gonna type FS
not read directory now the first
argument is going to be obviously the
name of the directory and in this case
we call it example and then the second
argument is going to be a callback
function first parameter is going to be
error and then second parameter is going
to have files now files is going to be
an array with the name of the file so
now you can test if there's an error all
we're going to do is print out the error
there's no error we're going to print
out files and I'm just going to print
out files just to show you
what files contains so if I save this
run this and the console you can see
that we have our two files stored within
an array a dot txt and B dot txt so now
let's actually loot through this array
and delete everything so now I'm just
going to say for let file of files and
then within here we can start deleting
each file individually so I could say FS
the unlink and then we're gonna give it
the file name so it's gonna be dot
forward slash example then it's gonna be
the name of the file after that is gonna
take in an argument call back with an
error and if there was a problem
deleting to have file it's gonna print
it out to the console if there wasn't
we're just gonna say successfully
deleted file so and so so so
successfully deleted file so now if I
was to save this and now execute this
you can see successfully delete file
once twice and if I have control B you
can see that we have an empty folder
called example
in this tutorial
talking about the readable and writeable
screams now what these screams allow us
to do is basically be able to read and
write data more efficiently and the way
that they accomplish this is by reading
and writing data and chunks as opposed
to reading and writing the data all at
once so to get started we're going to
have to require the fs module or the
filesystem module so I'm just going to
say Const FS is equal to require FS now
that we have our file system module
include it we're going to create a
readable stream and there's a method
called FS that create read screen and
now I need to give it the path so if I
just hit ctrl B you can see that I have
an example dot txt file here and it has
a bunch of text that we're going to be
reading in so if I head back to app that
ge'ez hit ctrl B again we're just going
to give it the path of dot for it slash
example dot txt and then that's it now
this is going to return to us a readable
stream so I'm just going to save it
within a variable so I'm just going to
say cons read stream is equal to FS 3
treem and then here what we can do is
listen for an event
now the reaching object inherits from
the event emitter class so that means we
could listen for events to occur and one
event that we want to listen for is the
data event so I'm just going to say we
each stream dot on data and then this is
going to take a callback function and
now we're going to get a chunk of data
in return so every time you read a piece
of data this event data is going to be
invoked so this callback function is
going to be called every time we get a
piece of data so now I'm just going to
print out the data onto the console
and you're gonna see why I call it a
chunk and not the full file in a second
so now if I save this go to node app and
you can see that we've read this data
within two chunks so we have two
printouts here we have a buffer here and
a buffer here so let's actually set the
encoding type so it's a lot easier to
what the source is and we're just going
to set it to utf-8 and save this and now
let's rerun this application and there
you go you see that we've read our text
file so what are the benefits of reading
this in a chunk as opposed to loading
the whole file well for one when I get
this chunk I could immediately start
manipulating that chunk so I don't have
to wait for the whole file to load in
order to manipulate it or let's say that
I don't want to manipulate this chunk of
data that I got already I want to send
it to a new file well I could start
sending that data to a new file while
I'm reading in the data itself
so let's actually send it to a new file
and for that we're gonna have to create
a writable stream so I'm just going to
go here and I'm gonna say cons right
stream is equal to FS that create right
stream and within here is going to be
the name of the file that I want to
write to so I'm just gonna call it
example 2 dot txt and now within here
what I can do is instead of waiting to
get the whole data I could start writing
chunks to the new file so if in here
instead of just printing out console dot
log chunk I can say write stream dot
write and I could write this data to a
new file as I'm reading it in so I could
say chunk here and let's save that and
now
run this application note app so now if
I hit control B you guys see our newly
created file and if I go here you can
see that we wrote on to a new file so
basically what's happening here is I'm
able to write chunk by chunk and our
example two chunks in order to get the
full file I'm able to start writing
before the file is fully loaded and
that's pretty much the power of using a
stream
in this tutorial
show you guys why you should be using
streams by trying to read a very very
large text file so to get started I'm
just gonna show you how big the file is
so I'm just gonna hit control B we have
our large file txt file here and if I
click reveal and Explorer right click
properties you can see that the size
it's about 2.7 gigs so let's actually
take a look at what would happen if we
were to use the read file method from
the file system module so now if I was
to execute this and type node app you
see that we get an error and the error
says file size is greater than the
possible buffer now what does that mean
well the read file uses a buffer but it
uses a full buffer now what that means
is that I need at least 2.7 gigs in
memory in order to load this file
because this file has to be loaded
because this file has to fit within the
buffer and it's saying hey your buffer
size is just too small for this file now
I'm just gonna comment this out and now
what we're gonna use is a readable
screen so I'm just gonna comment this up
and then we're gonna uncomment this and
by the way I have tutorials on both
readable streams and using the read file
method so now I have this stream but
look what happens when I execute the
code now so if I was to save this and
now execute it you can see that our
readable stream has absolutely no
problem reading this file so I'm just
gonna hit ctrl C to cancel this because
I don't want it to finish
you know loading the entire thing but
why can this be accomplished with
streams but not using this read file
method
well one a screen uses a buffer also but
it doesn't use a full buffer it uses a
very very
small buffer and what that allows us to
do is basically what's happening is that
you're ending out reading the file in
chunks you're not reading the entire
file at once so basically every time a
data event occurs I am getting a chunk
of the file I'm not attempting to read
the entire file at once and therefore
the buffer size could be a lot smaller
as opposed to the read file method which
uses a full buffer which needs to be big
enough to load the entire file at once
and then serve it streams allow for a
smaller buffer size which is memory
efficient and for data to be read and
written in chunks
in this tutorial
me going over pipes now what a pipe
allows us to do is basically take a
sewer stream which is just a readable
stream and send it over to his
destination which is just a writable
stream so in the last tutorial we went
over readable streams and writable
streams and basically what we did was
create a read stream and then from there
we created a write dream and then we
attached an event listener to the read
stream and every time we got a data
event emitted we read a piece of a chunk
from the restream and then rewrote out
that chunk to where we want it to send
it so there's actually a much more
simpler way and the much more simpler
way is just to get rid of this and all
we're going to do is say reach dream dot
pipe now pipe is going to take what read
stream gives us and it's going to pipe
it into our write screen so now if I was
to bring up the terminal and just type
node app and hit control B you can see
all right we have our example text and
then we created our example 2 dot txt so
the pipe method is basically a shorthand
version for all of that stuff that we
wrote in the last tutorial so all we
need to remember it is in order to use a
pipe we need two streams we need a
source stream and we also need a
destination stream in our case the reach
stream is our source this is the file
that we want to read in then we call the
pipe method on the restream and then
this is going to take the destination
where do we want to send this data to
and that's through the right stream so
now I want to talk about pipe chaining
so let's give a more complicated example
and for that I'm going to bring in
another module and I'm gonna bring in
Kant's Zee Lib now Zee Lib is a module
that is for basically compression
compressing files I'm just gonna say
require
z lid now what we're going to do is
create a transform screen now what a
transform stream is basically is what it
does is it takes the input so for
example from our read stream and then
when it receives that data it
manipulates that data into something
else in this case what it's going to do
is compress the data so I'm just going
to create a transform stream so I'm just
going to say conce gzip is equal to Z
Lib dot create gzip I'll call that
method now this is going to return our
transform screen and now within here
instead of saying reach dream what I can
do is send that data that reach dream is
giving us and I could pipe it into our
gzip now what
is going to do is take the chunks of
data that is reading at a time and it's
going to manipulate it and compress it
basically so you're going to get a
compressed version of the read stream
and then from here we're going to pipe
it out to our destination which is our
write stream so now that was the run
this let's save it now I'm just going to
hit ctrl B and if we go here to example
2 dot txt you can see that we
accidentally did not change the type and
that's my fault
so the type that we're creating create
write stream should not be a txt file it
should be a dot GZ file and that's the
compression type so I'm just going to
save this and let's run this application
again now I'm going to hit ctrl B and
you can see that we get an example to
dot txt GZ file now if I click it it's
going to say that visual studio code can
not open this so I'm just going to
right-click it reveal and Explorer and
you can see that is a zip file is
basically a compressed file and I'm
going to double click it and you can see
that our example 2 dot txt files here
and with our text so now let's give just
one more example just to get the hang of
it of chaining pipes and using a
transform stream so we saw what happens
when we compress the file and then write
it so let's go in reverse we're going to
take our source which is compressed
we're going to uncompress it and then
we're going to write it so from here
let's just go back to visual studio code
let's go back to app dot J yes control B
and instead of saying create gzip what
we want to do is create unzip so I'm
just going to go here and say create g
unzip and we're going to change this
variable to
zip and now this is going to be our
transform screen so I'm just gonna copy
this paste it here and now what happened
well restream has changed right so now I
want the compressed version of it so
let's go over here we're going to get
rid of done coding type the compressed
file is called example two dot txt GZ so
I'm just going to copy this I'm going to
paste this in here now this input this
read stream is going to be piped to G
unzip which is going to basically
uncompress the file and that is going to
send it off to our destination so what
do we want our destination to be called
and we could pretty much name this
anything you want so I'm just going to
say uncompressed dot txt so now if I was
to go ahead and save this type node app
execute it we hit ctrl B and you can see
that we have our uncompressed txt file
so if I click this you can see our
example text is here and that it is
successfully uncompressed
in this tutorial we're going to go over
the HTTP module now what the HTTP module
allows us to do is basically create a
web server with node.js so to get
started we're going to have to require
the HTTP module so I'm just going to say
Const HTTP is equal to require HTTP now
from here we can call a method called
create server and this is going to give
us a HTTP server object so I'm just
going to say cons server is equal to
http dot create server now this method
is going to take a callback and this
callback is going to give us a request
object as well as a response object so
let's just do that
now the request object is what the
client requests from us so for example
if I am on Google Chrome and I type in
WWI comm I am requesting something from
Google now Google server is going to
take that request and is going to send
me a response back so the most
simplistic example that I could give you
is I could send a basic text back to the
client so I can say Res and that's gonna
be my response I'm gonna say right and
I'm just gonna pass in a string so I'm
just gonna say hello world from node J
yes
now within here I haven't actually sent
the response back I just told it what it
is so in order to send the response I'm
going to say res dot end now this
going to take care of our HTTP dot
create server method now there's one
more thing that we have to do to get
this server up and running and that's
the tone ojs what port that I want to
listen for request that so I'm just
gonna say server not listen and we're
gonna listen on port 3000 so now if I
was to save this and now go down here
type a node app you can see that our
server is up and running now I'm going
to go to Chrome and within here I'm
going to type local host :
and then the port which we assigned was
3000 so that's where we're listening for
requests that if I hit enter you can see
that we get a response back from the
server
hello world from node ajs so now from
here what we can do is actually listen
to requests different routes
so let's actually take a look at a
property of the request object and one
of the properties is called
URL so instead of just saying hello
world from nodejs i only want to say
hello world from nodejs if it is the
root domain so I'm just gonna say
request dot URL is equal to forward
slash then I'm gonna say res dot write
hello world from node J s and then don't
forget that we have to send the response
back to the client so we're going to
call res dot end and now if I was to
save this and we're just going to hit
ctrl C to kick us out of the server and
then we're going to start the server
back up again so we get our updated
changes we're going to go back to Chrome
hit enter and you
see that it works exactly the same if we
were to add an else statement here so
let's say they are not using the root
domain I can say res doc right using
some other domain and then we're going
to send that out to the user and let's
actually control see this to stop the
server and before we start up the server
I have to save so I'm just going to say
ctrl s to save node app and now here
instead of localhost colon 3000 I'm
gonna say localhost banana and let's see
what response we get and the response we
get back is using some alert domain now
this response is going to be for
anything we type because we put it in
the else block so if I type that I'm
gonna get the same response and then if
I go back and just have the forward
slash you can see that we get the hello
world from nodejs
output
in this tutorial
can serve static files using the HTTP
and filesystem module so to get started
I'm just gonna hit control B to bring up
the package explorer and you can see
that we have a static folder and we have
three static files now these files is a
JSON file an image a PNG file and an
index.html file so what I want to do is
make a request to the server and have
the server send these files back to me
so I'm just going to hit ctrl B to get
rid of that and the first thing we're
going to do is actually require the
modules on this going to say cons HTTP
equal require HTTP and then our second
module is going to be the file system
module so I'm just gonna say require FS
now the first step to do this is to
actually create the server so I'm just
gonna say HTTP dot create server and
this is gonna take a call back and we're
gonna have a request object and a
response object now I'm going to call
and method on that server object so I'm
just gonna say dot listen and we're
gonna listen on port 3000 now let's say
that I want to read in a HTML file for
instance so let's go up here and what I
can do is create a readable screen so
I'm just gonna say cons reach dream it's
going to be equal to FS dot create read
screen and then within here we're gonna
pass in the path so I'm going to say dot
forward slash because it's going to be
relative to app KS now I need to go
inside the static folder and then the
name of the file that I want to read in
is called index dot HTML now what I want
to do is actually write a header for my
response now what a header is
responsible for is to let the client
know what kind of data that I am
expecting so I'm just gonna say res dot
right head and then within here we're
gonna pass in the HTTP status code so
I'm gonna pass in 200 now 200 means that
everything went okay with your request
and then the second argument is going to
be what the content type is so I'm just
gonna hit content type and then we're
going to pass it in text slash HTML all
right so now that we've written our
header I'm just gonna take you guys to
Google Chrome real quick just to look up
the status codes now you can see that
HTTP 200 means that the request has been
successfully completed so whatever the
user requested from the server that
means everything went fine as I said and
there's a bunch of HTTP status code so
let's look at another one so another
common one is 4 or 4 so you're going on
a website and you accidentally miss type
the URL and they give you a not found
error so that would be a 404 error now
let's go back to our visual studio code
and let's complete this so I'm just
gonna go down here and within here I'm
just gonna pipe the read stream in to
where I want to send it so I'm just
gonna say read stream dot type and where
do I want to send this file I want to
send it to the user so I'm gonna pass in
res now res the response object is also
a writable extreme so I'm piping it to
the response object so now I'm just
gonna save this let's go back to Chrome
I'm gonna go here Google and I'm gonna
type localhost 3,000 and I should
probably be be noted that you should
start up your node applications I'm just
gonna type node app
now let's go back to Google Chrome hit
refresh and you can see that our HTML
file has been successfully sent so let's
actually try to send the other static
files and this is pretty much straight
forward so all we have is if I hit ctrl
B is in image and a JSON file so I'm
just going to hit ctrl B again now all
we need to do is obviously change the
file that we're reading in so instead of
index.html let's do example JSON now the
content type is obviously not a text
slash HTML file so we're going to have
to pass in application slash JSON and
now if I was to save this hit control-c
so we're going to restart the server I'm
just going to clear out the terminal
node app now let's hit refresh and you
can see that our JSON file gets loaded
and sent to the client now let's load up
that image so now the same exact thing
I'm just going to hit ctrl because I
forgot when I named the image I named it
example dot PNG I'm just going to change
this to PNG and instead of application
dot JSON we're just gonna remove this
and we're just gonna go here and type
image slash PNG so now if I was to save
this now we got to restart the server
ctrl C to cancel that out no app now if
I go to Chrome hit refresh you can see
that my image has been loaded so that's
basically the ends and outs of how you
would serve a static file using the HTTP
module as well as the file system module
in this tutorial
how we can create our package.json file
now what the package.json file is
responsible for is basically holding all
our metadata for our project metadata
being the name of the project the
version number etc so to get started
what we're gonna use is call it the node
package manager so I'm just gonna type
NPM and then I'm gonna type in it which
means initialize I hit enter and you can
see that we get a bunch of jargon so
what do we want to name the package by
default is going to be called the name
of the folder that you're currently in
so up here you can see no GS underscore
tutorial and it says the default will be
no GS / tutorial so I could just hit
enter that's fine with me
the version number one point 0.0 that's
okay
description so what is this package
about what is your project about and
we're just gonna say tutorial because
that's all we're using it for and then
the entry point is pretty important and
it lets us know which file should be
used to start our node application so
for example if I was making a website
and I upload it to a server it would let
the server know that that was our entry
point to our application test command
let's ignore that for now hit enter and
get repository is pretty
self-explanatory it's gonna be your get
URL hit enter keywords we're gonna leave
that blank as well author go ahead and
write down your name license IOC is
provide by me then he's gonna say is
this ok and we're just gonna say yeah
that's fine so you might think that
nothing has happened but if I hit ctrl B
you can see that we have our package
JSON file created and if I take a look
at this open it up you can see that
package dot JSON is just a JSON file
has our configuration settings so the
name the version description of our
application the entry point scripts
author and license and basically in the
next tutorial what we're going to end up
doing is actually going out and stalling
external packages and including them
within our own project
this tutorial we're going to be
/ the node package manager in order to
install packages now our package is is
basically reusable code that we can
include within our own application
it's a folder with one or more modules
within it so to get started we're
actually gonna head over to Chrome real
quick and there's actually a website
called NPM Jas calm now
NPM Jas calm is where we can actually
look and discover new packages that we
can include within our application so
I'm just going to pick out a package and
we're going to install it and then use
it so I'm just gonna scroll down and you
can use the search up here or let's just
pick a popular package so you can see
packages that a lot of people are
installing and scroll down more and
let's pick low - and then here we're
given a bunch of instructions so I says
in order to install this package I just
have to type in this command NPM I is
shorthand for install and then the name
of the package so in this case the
packages name is low - so if I head back
to Visual Studio code and I type NPM
install low - you can see that it goes
out and it downloads the package for me
automatically and now if I head back to
my package JSON file the JSON file that
we created in the previous tutorial
you'll notice that we have an extra
property and within this property is
called dependencies and then it gives us
the name of the package we installed as
well as the package version that we
installed so now if I was just to hit
ctrl B you would see that we have a
extra folder and this extra folder is
called node modules so if I open this up
you can see that our lodash installation
is
word here within this folder so now this
is all fine and dandy but how would I
now use lodash within my own personal
project so I'm just going to hit control
B and we're going to close out our
package.json file we're going to go to
AB dot Jas and basically what we're
going to do is require it so I'm just
gonna say Kant's underscore is equal to
require low - and now from here let's
actually use it let's prove that this is
working so I'm just gonna say underscore
dot fill and fill is basically gonna
take an array so I'm just gonna pass in
an array 1 2 3 4 5 and the second
argument is gonna take in a value what
do you want to replace these numbers
were so I'm just gonna say banana and
the third argument is gonna be the start
index so what I want to do is start at
index 1 and the last argument is going
to be the end index and since we have 5
elements within our array the last index
would be 4 so let's actually store this
within a variable so I'm just gonna say
that example is equal to that and we're
just going to print out this onto the
console so I'm just going to hit ctrl s
to save I'm going to go to note app and
you can see that we require lodash into
our application and we've tested that
one of the methods within lodash is
actually working so we get a new array
and we filled in index 1 2 3 with the
value of banana and let's say
for whatever instance that you installed
the wrong module or you want to get rid
of a module so if I hit control B and
we're just going to bring out the
package.json file and then hit control B
again what I can do is I can say NPM
uninstall and then the package name
which is going to be low - and you can
see that low - is removed from our
dependencies and if I hit control B you
can see that our node underscore modules
folder no longer exists and that's
because we have no dependencies that our
application is using currently
in this tutorial I'm going to be talking
about semantic versioning now what
semantic versioning is is basically just
a standard that a lot of node.js
packages follow it allows for us to know
what kind of changes have occurred in
the updated version of the package so to
get started you can see that I have my
package JSON file open and I have a
dependency install called lodash now
within here you see the version of the
package that I installed with the carrot
sign and we'll talk about the carrot
sign within this tutorial as well but
for now I want you to focus on these
three numbers the first number four is
going to represent the major version of
this package the second number is going
to represent the minor version and the
third number is going to represent the
patch version now the major minor and
patch numbers all have different
meanings so for example right now the
latest version is 4.17 dot 11 if I wake
up tomorrow and lodash is updated and it
says the latest version is 4.17 dot 12
that means that that was a patch update
now all a patch update means is that
they implemented some bug fixes now
likewise same thing happens I go to
sleep they update lodash tomorrow and
instead of 4.17 dot 11 is 4.18 dot 11 so
that means that there was a minor update
now what a minor update does is it adds
new functionality and it might
deprecated some of the old functionality
but you can still use it so it's a
non-breaking change update and finally
if I was to go to sleep tomorrow and
wake up new version of lodash is updated
and this time we get version 5.0 dot 0
so what does that mean that means that
there was a major update pushed out to
lodash
and what a major update indicates is
that there was a breaking change so that
means version 5.0 zero is not compatible
with the code for point 17 dot 11 or any
version of four so now let's talk about
this caret character and this caret
character was put there automatically
when we typed npm install
lodash now what this caret character
symbolizes the following so the
following rules if you will so this
means that whenever I use the caret
character that I do not want you to make
any major updates so that means right
now I'm on version 4 as the major but if
there is a minor update or a patch
update go ahead and download those new
packages now there's another symbol
called the tilde symbol and tilde symbol
is right next to the number one on your
keypad and that means that you want the
following to occur that means you only
want patch updates so let's say I'm on
4.17 right now that means I only want
you to change the last number so for
example if 4.18 comes out this tilde
symbol will say hey do not update to
that package and last but not least
let's say that you don't want the tilde
or the caret sign up here so for example
you don't want the caret sign to update
the minor or the patch and you don't
want the tilde to just update the patch
what you can do is remove the caret or 2
tilde sign and this guarantees that the
only version of lodash that you will
ever have within your package will be
4.17 dot 11
in this tutorial
to set up our first expression server
now all Express is is basically a web
framework for nodejs so in the previous
tutorials we use the HTTP and filesystem
module in order to serve static files
with expressed however you can see that
we can accomplish that and much more
with much less code so to get started
I'm just gonna go over to Chrome and
here is Express JSS official web site so
you can see up here that they have
guides for you
you could reference the API and
basically this is just a documentation
for Express and you can see that they
give install instructions here now if
you didn't go to the official website or
you didn't know that they had an
official website you probably would have
went to MP MJS com the Express is a
publicly available package for you to
download and install and you would have
just typed expressed within the search
bar here so I'm just gonna head back to
Visual Studio code and the first thing
that we need to do is actually create
our package JSON so I'm just gonna say
NPM in it and I'm gonna pass in the flag
yes now when you pass in the flag yes
you basically skip all these
configuration questions that they ask
you when you type NPM in it so now that
we have our package JSON we actually
install express itself so I'm just going
to type NPM install Express you can see
that is downloading right now and now
from here let's actually require
expressed a yes into our project so I'm
just gonna say cons Express is equal to
require Express now when I require this
module this Express module when I'm
getting back is a function so I'm just
gonna call that function so I'm just
gonna say Express
and this function is going to return an
object and this object is going to have
a bunch of methods that we can use
within our application so let's store
this object within a variable and by
convention we would call that variable
app so I'm just going to say app is
equal to Express now from here what I
can do is call a method called and get
now the first argument of get is going
to take the route so we're just going to
say for it slash and then the second
argument is going to be the callback
function and it's going to be request
and response and then all we're gonna do
is say res dot send hello world so this
is going to be our first application
using Express so when the user visits
the route forward slash what we're going
to do is send a response of hello world
and that with a semicolon and then the
last step that we need to do is actually
give it a port to listen to so I'm just
gonna say app dot listen and we're just
going to listen on port 3000 so now if I
was to save this type note app and
that's going to run the server head over
to Chrome now I'm just going to open a
new tab and I'm just gonna type
localhost 3,000 and there you go this is
our first Express j/s application and
you can see that we got a response of
hello world and in the upcoming
tutorials we're gonna dive deeper into
the Express web framework
in this tutorial we're gonna work more
with the HTTP GET request and we're
gonna be talking about Curie string and
route parameters so to get started we
created a basic Express application from
the previous tutorial and we gave it one
route which is basically the index route
or you could refer to it as the home
page and we just said hello world so if
I was just to run this node app go to
Chrome go to local host and we're gonna
put 3000 because that's the port and you
see our basic route so this is the
forward slash route so now let's give it
another route so I'm just gonna go here
I'm just gonna say app dot get and we're
gonna give it another route and I'm just
gonna say example and within here we're
gonna pass in a callback and now we're
just gonna say res dots and hitting
example route so now if I save this I'm
just gonna hit ctrl C to kick us out
we're gonna restart the server so that
it starts with our newly saved file head
over to Chrome hit refresh you see that
our index page is still working and if I
go here and type example you can see
that we create another row and that it's
hitting the example route now as opposed
to the index route so now let's go back
here this is all fine and dandy now I
want to talk about Kure strings and
route parameters so I want to start off
with route parameters and we're gonna
create another route so I'm just gonna
say app dot yet and I'm gonna say
example and within here I'm gonna give
it these : and I'm just gonna say name
and that's gonna be the name of that
route and I'm just gonna say H
and then the same exact thing so I'm
just going to pass in a callback don't
forget to add that and then this time
what I want to do is access from the
request object and I'm just going to say
params and what we want to do is
actually print this out onto the console
to see what we get and the idea is that
I want to get the value of name and age
so we're just gonna say res dot send and
we're just gonna say hitting actually
let's say example with route params so
we're just gonna save this hit control-c
I'm just gonna say CLS no app head over
to Chrome we're gonna hit refresh so our
example is working but now we're gonna
pass information in so I'm just gonna
pass in name so Pedro and then age I'm
gonna put 99 so I'm going to hit enter
and you can see example with route
params has been executed so now if I
take a look back at Visual Studio code
you can see that when we hit this route
here and we print out what's within our
request dot params we get an object and
this object contains the property's name
and age and the values of Pedro and 99
so let's give a more detailed example
instead of just giving a generic answer
I'm just gonna print send the user back
his name so I say name plus here I'm
just gonna say H
and don't forget that this name property
and age is within our requests dot
params and all requests stop params is
is an object so I could say request dot
per am dot name to access the name value
and I could say request dot params dot
age to access the age property so now if
I save this and we're going to reset the
server CLS to clear the terminal node
app head over to Chrome hit refresh and
you can see that we're sending back to
the user pedro in ninety nine and that
we get the same output because we're
still printing it so that's how we would
get data from the user using route
parameters but there's also another type
of data that you can send back and
that's called Curie string parameters so
what is that well if I go back here and
actually let me just type this out I'm
gonna say console dot log and again
we're going to use the request object
because the request object is basically
what the client is sending us so I'm
just gonna say request dot Curie and
here in Google Chrome let's actually
cancel this server I'm going to save
this file restart the server head over
to Chrome just going to go up here hit
refresh go back to visual studio code
and you can see that we get an empty
object now this empty object is going to
be our request doc Curie so it's just a
Curie string parameter and the reason
it's an empty object is because we
haven't actually passed anything into it
so in order to do that I'm just going to
go up here we're going to use a question
mark and then it's going to be the name
of the property that you want so I'm
just
make it up right now I'm gonna give it a
name of tutorial and then followed by
equal sign and then the value you want
to assign it so I'm just gonna say
params tutorial and now if I hit enter
here you can see that's pretty much the
same thing that's happening but if I go
back to visual studio code you can see
that our requests Curie object is no
longer empty we have a property of
tutorial and we have params tutorial as
a value so now let's say that I want to
pass more than just the tutorial so how
would I pass multiple kiri string
parameters and if we head back to Chrome
all we have to do is remember to start
off with question mark the name of the
query string and then the value so if
you want to pass in a second Curie
string what you can do is use the + sign
or the ampere stamp or whatever you want
to call it and I'm just going to give it
sort and then I'm just going to say
equal and I'm going to give it the value
of by age and if I hit enter head over
to Visual Studio code and you can see
now that when we print out our Curie
string you can see that we get an object
that has tutorial and it also has the
property of sort so now you might be
asking yourselves when should I use a
route parameter verse a tree string
parameter you should use route
parameters when you must have that beta
so for example let's say name was an
absolute must I cannot have a blank name
and I cannot have a blank age so I would
use a route parameter and let's say that
I want to give some optional settings in
that case I would use a query string
parameter so for example when we pass
then sort
we could be sorting the data by age and
that would be an optional setting but I
would need the name and the age to begin
with so I would use a route parameter
for that and if the user wants to sort
the data then I will use a Curie string
parameter for that
in this tutorial
serving static files using Express now
what do I mean by a static file I mean
your HTML files CSS client-side
JavaScript images videos stuff like that
so to get started we're just going to
require a path module and it's basically
a utility module that deals with paths
just to make our lives a little bit
easier and within here if I go down here
I can say app not use now use whenever
you see a pot use it means that I'm
using middleware the first argument is
going to be the alias for our static
folder so for example if I was to hit
ctrl B you can see that I have a static
folder here and what I want to do is
give this static folder an alias
I don't want people outside of my server
to know it that this folder is called
static but let's take a look inside of
it we have an index.html we have
examples a s and we have a main dot CSS
file just for an an example so now if I
close that control B I'm gonna call it
public that's going to be the alias for
my static folder the second argument is
going to be a middleware function so I'm
going to use a convenience method that
Express provides us so I could say
express dot static and then I'm going to
path join and Seder name which stands
for directory name now their name is a
string and this is going to give us
where app dot J s is so if we take a
look by pressing ctrl B is going to give
us where app dot j s is located now I
want to go inside to the static folder
because this is where all my static
assets are so if I hit control B again
we'll pass in as a second argument the
name of the folder static so I'm just
gonna end this call in there
says there's some error and I'm missing
a parenthesis so now here instead of
just saying hello world let's actually
send a file so I'm just gonna remove
this say res dot send file and we're
going to use our path module again to
make things easier I'm going to say path
by join we're going to give it the
directory name that we're currently in
we're going to go inside the static
folder and then I want to serve the HTML
file so the HTML file is called index
dot HTML so now if I was to save this go
down here tight note app let's go over
to Chrome now we're going to go up here
type localhost 3000 and there you go you
can see our static HTML file has been
served if I type f12 let's take a look
at the source real quick like actually
see it and you can see within our HTML
file that we're using public now
remember we don't actually have a folder
called public we have a folder called
static but to the client-side is
public and this main dot CSS file now
this main dot CSS file is working
because you can see that our h1 tag is
read and now if we go back down here you
can see public j/s and our example J yes
and if I go to console you can see that
I print it out on to the console
testing client side so that's basically
the basics of serving static files using
Express now you can use this to use
images and videos and it'll be the same
exact process
in this tutorial we're going to be
handling an HTTP POST request using
Express now an HTTP POST request is
typically used when working with forms
so I have my form set up right here I
have an email address field and a
password field and if I was to hit
submit that would be an example of a
post request now obviously we're getting
an error from node cannot post to this
route that's because we haven't actually
coded anything yet so if we take a look
at Visual Studio code you can see our
form that I set up action is going to be
the route that we're going to code so I
just put forward slash the HTTP method
is gonna be a post method here we see
that we have our email field and our
password field and our button of type
submit' so now I'm just going to head
over to app that Jess and I actually
want to code the app that post method so
if we take a look at our application as
it sits currently all I have is an app
that get this is the route and all I'm
doing is serving the HTML file to the
user so in order to remedy this we're
gonna use a module that's going to parse
the form data for us and that module is
called the body parser module and that
module is called the body parsing module
so to get started we're actually going
to have to install this module so I'm
just going to come down here cancel our
server I'm going to say npm install body
parser so let that install and now from
here what we're going to do is require
it into our application so I'm just
going to say cons body parser is equal
to require body parser
and now from here what we're gonna do is
use middleware so every time we use
middleware we're gonna call app dot use
so here I'm just gonna say app dot use
then I'm gonna say body parser dot URL
encode it and then within here we're
gonna pass in an option called
extend it and we're gonna set that to
false so end that with a semicolon and
all this is doing is allowing us to
parse URL encoded forms it parses the
data for us and attaches it to the
requested body the extended option is
set to false because we aren't dealing
with any complicated objects all we want
is an email and password which are both
strings so now that we have that setup
let's actually code our app that post
HTTP requests so we have our get here
and now I'm just going to go down here
and instead of saying app get I'm going
to say app dot post the first argument
is going to be the route and as you saw
in the HTML file the action route is the
forward slash the second argument is
going to be a callback function with the
request and res object and now from here
remember what the body parser does it
parses the data for us and it attaches
it to the body but the request object so
now what I can do here is I can say
console dot log request that body and
this is going to give us an object with
the properties of email and password and
now from here usually when you post
something to the server you usually use
whatever the user input it and you do
some database work so I'm just gonna say
database work here and once that
database work is done you were sent a
response to a user so I'm just gonna say
res dot send
successfully posted data now I'm just
gonna hit ctrl s to save go down here
I'm going to type a node app start up my
server let's head over to Chrome and now
if I hit refresh just to reload it let's
type some random email random password
hit submit so now what happened here was
I filled in my email and password I post
it to the server I got a response back
from the server saying everything was
posted successfully so if I go back to
visual studio code you can see that our
console dot log is working we're
printing out the request dot body and
you can see that our form data has been
successfully parsed so if we take a look
down here onto the console you'll see
that we have an object with the property
email and its value and you also have
property of password and its value so
that's pretty much how you would make an
HTTP POST request using Express and the
body parser module
in this tutorial
how we can handle JSON data using
Express and the body parser module so in
the previous tutorial we talked about
using the body person module in order to
handle URL encoded data so what we're
going to do is take this form from the
last tutorial and convert it to post
JSON data so to get started I'm just
gonna head over to Visual Studio code
and right here I have on my index.html
file and our form pulled up what I'm
gonna do is add an attribute to the form
so I'm just going to give it an ID and
I'm going to call it form and the reason
for that is I want to prevent the
defaults on mission I want to post theta
using jQuery AJAX so that's how we're
going to post JSON data to our server so
now that I have my ID scroll down and I
already put our jQuery CD in here just
to make the tutorial a little bit
quicker and we're just going to go here
and we're going to include our script so
I'm just gonna say script now from here
we're just gonna say document dot ready
and the first
do is get our form so I'll just say
dollar sign pound sign form and we're
going to attach a submit handler to our
form and this submit handler is going to
take a callback function which has an
event as a parameter so now what I want
to do is prevent the default submit so
we're just going to take the event that
we get and we're going to call prevent
default and from here we're going to use
Ajax to actually make the post request
and what we're going to do is post JSON
data back to the server so I'm just
gonna say the dollar sign Ajax and this
is going to take a bunch of
configuration so one of the properties
that we can use is called URL and this
is going to be the endpoint that we're
gonna have at our server so I'm just
gonna say forward slash second property
is going to be type and there's going to
be what kind of HTTP request that we
want to make and we're going to post
JSON to the server so I'm just gonna say
post third argument is going to be the
content type and the content type is
obviously going to be JSON so I'm just
gonna say application slash JSON next
that we're gonna use is called data and
this is going to be the actual form data
that we want to pass in so how do we get
the form data well I'm just going to say
get our form and then I'm going to
serialize it using the serialized array
and basically this is going to take our
form data so our email field and our
password field serialize it within an
array and that's going to be a
JavaScript array object but remember
we're posting JSON back to the server
because that's the content type that we
want so we're just going to say json dot
stringify and pass in this data as an
argument so this is going to take the
serialized array and it's going to
convert it into JSON for us next we're
going to say success and success is
going to be invoked when we have
successful response back from the server
so I'm just gonna say response and we're
just gonna print onto the console
successfully got response and we're also
gonna print out the response that we
actually got from the server so once all
this is done let's scroll down a bit
everything looks good to me so I'm just
gonna save our index.html file we're
gonna head back to app chaos so this is
our server and down here remember that
we told our Express application how to
handle URL encoded data now what we need
to do is just say F that use body parser
and this has a method called JSON now
this method is obviously going to parse
in JSON and it's going to attach it to
our request dot body so now if I just
put a semicolon there and if we scroll
back down you can see our original post
request is handled here
what I'm gonna do is instead of saying
just plain text we're gonna respond back
to the client using JSON so I'm just
gonna say res dot JSON and we're gonna
pass an object and we're just gonna say
that it's been successfully posted so
now obviously what rezzed I Jason does
is takes a JavaScript object and
converts it into JSON for us so now if I
was to save this and I'm just gonna go
to terminal new terminal and I'm gonna
say node app to run the server go back
to Chrome when I type localhost and now
to test this out let's give it a dummy
email and password click Submit and now
if I hit f12 you can see form serial
array is not a function so let's take a
look at this and we're getting an error
let's actually take a look at that part
of the code and that's because we did
not include the dollar sign
so let's include that now let's save it
go over to Chrome now we're gonna hit
refresh and type whatever we want hit
submit go to console and you can see
that we successfully post it JSON to the
server the server responded by posting
this object back to us if I go back to
visual studio code you can see that we
have our serialized form data you can
see that we have our
form data and that it's not JSON that
this is just an array and the reason why
you're not getting back JSON and it's
because our body parts are module sees
that it's JSON and automatically
converts it to a JavaScript object in
this case it's an array
and in this tutorial we're going to be
talking about validating user input
using joy so what we're going to do is
validate the data coming in from this
form now the reason you would validate
user input server-side is because you
can never trust the data that you're
receiving from the user so to get
started let's actually head over to
Visual Studio code and I'm just gonna
cancel out our server and I'm gonna type
NPM install joy and this is going to
install the joy module now from here
what we're going to do is actually
require it into our application so I'm
going to go up here I'm going to type
Const joy is equal to require joy so now
that we have joy in our application
let's actually go down to our request
so we have our get request which
basically serves the form to our user
and we have our post request which is
going to get the data from our user so
from here what we want to do is actually
validate the data that we get within our
request body and in order to do that
what we're going to do is create a
schema so what's a schema a schema is
basically a blueprint a set of rules
that we want our data to have so we have
an email field and we have a password
field so what I want to do is make sure
that the email that the user gives me is
a valid email and likewise with the
password field so what we can do here is
I come down here and we can create a
schema now remember this is just a
blueprint I'm gonna say joy dot object
now this is going to give us a joy
object next thing we need to do is call
a method called keys now keys is going
to work the same way that a regular
JavaScript file would work you would
have your key value pairs and we're
gonna pass in the options now within
here what we want to do is set the rules
that the data that we're receiving must
follow so we have a field called email
and within here I'm going to say joy I'm
gonna say string so what I'm saying is
the email field must be a string value
I'm going to trim that data that I'm
receiving I'm gonna call a method called
email and this is going to check to see
whether or not this is a valid email and
I'm gonna call one more method called
required now required does is if the
user sends me a null email in other
words the user doesn't fill out an email
I'm gonna get an error because this
field is required so let's go back to
our another property and the next
property we have is password so from
here I'm gonna do the same thing joy I
need it to be of type string and let's
change it up for the password field so
let's say that I need the password to be
at least five characters so I'm gonna
call the min method I'm gonna pass in
five I'm gonna call the max method and
I'm gonna pass in ten so right now this
password must be a minimum of five
characters long and a maximum of ten
characters so between five and ten and
the last method I'm gonna call is
required and now let's end this with a
semicolon so now that we have our
blueprint let's actually use it so we're
gonna call a method called validate so
I'm just going to say joy not validate
and it's going to take three arguments
the first argument is the object that
you want to validate in this case
remember we use the body parser to parse
the form data and attach it to the body
of the request object so this is going
to be our first argument the second
argument is going to be our blueprint
which we just create it let's call it
schema
and our third argument is going to be
the callback function it's going to take
two parameters first one is going to be
an error second one is going to be
result and what we can do is find out
our results so if I say if error this is
going to execute true if there's
something wrong with the data so if
error is not null then this code will be
executed so if error is executed we know
something went wrong so I'm just gonna
say res dot sin and error has occurred
but if there is no error what we can do
is we could just say res dot send and I
can say successfully posted data now
just for the sake of this tutorial I'm
gonna print out result just so you can
see what the result is now the result is
basically just going to be the data that
we passed in so it's just going to be
the request body and I'm going to go up
here and I'm going to print out the
error object so now that I have these
two out what we can do is get rid of our
old code from the last tutorial I'm
actually going to save this I'm going to
type in node app
head over to Chrome and from here I'm
just gonna type in actually let's just
refresh the page real quick let's type
in an email and let's type in a password
and then if I hit submit you can see
successfully posted data so if I go back
to visual studio code you can see that
our email is right here and it probably
hit submit twice because I probably
clicked it twice and you can see that
our result that's getting printed out
it's just the request stop body is
whatever the user posted and you would
do all your database manipulation and
calls here so now let's actually go back
to Chrome and this time we're going to
type localhost again instead of giving
valid data let's see what happens when
we post invalid data so I'm gonna post
valid data for email and for the
password remember we have to give it
between 5 and 10 characters long so I'm
just gonna give it two characters long
and let's see what happens I'm gonna hit
submit and you can see the response we
get an error has occurred so let's
actually take a look at this in Visual
Studio code you can see this big long
mess of mumbo-jumbo so I'm just going to
go back up and you can see
that we're getting it says validation
error child password fails because
password must be at least five
characters long so you can see our
validation is working and this is pretty
much the ends and outs of validating
user input using joy
and this is going to be part two of my
joy validation tutorial so in this
tutorial we're gonna be covering how we
can validate a nested object as well as
how we can validate an array so to get
started I pretty much stripped out all
the Express stuff and we're gonna
simulate a user's request so for this
example we have this user input and it
is a nested object and it has a property
of personal info with the properties of
street address city and state and we
have preferences which is going to be
our array and you can see what values
the array contains here
so the first values that we're gonna
start off with our string values and
then we're gonna move on to objects so
the way that I'm gonna tackle this
problem is I'm gonna look at our user
input and I'm gonna break it down into
sections so for example I'm gonna
develop a schema for personal info and
then I'm gonna develop a schema for
preferences so to get started we're
gonna develop the personal info schema
first I'm just gonna copy this I'm gonna
come down here now I'm gonna say cons
personal info and then I'm just gonna
add schema next I'm gonna create a joy
object schema so I'm just gonna say joy
Dot object keys we're gonna hit enter
and I add a semicolon down here we're
gonna go up copy street address would
just develop a schema like we normally
would so I'm just gonna paste that
street address is gonna be joy dot
string dot trim I'm gonna make this
required we're gonna do the same thing
with the other properties go to city
copy this go down here paste and street
address in City we're gonna make the
same exact thing and last but not least
I'm going to take the state
and it's gonna be the same exact joy
schema except that we're gonna add that
it has to be a length of two so I'm just
going to copy this paste this here and
we're going to use the dot length method
and set that to two so we're going for
state abbreviations so now that we have
our personal info schema out of the way
let's develop a schema for preferences
so I'm gonna copy this we're gonna go
down here I'm gonna say cons preferences
schema and this time instead of using
joy dot object keys we're gonna say joy
dot array and this is going to give us
an array schema and we're gonna use a
helper method called items now what
items is going to take in as an argument
is basically any schema you want in this
case what we want is an array of strings
so I'm just gonna pass in the schema joy
dot string so this is going to make sure
that all the items that within the array
are all strings last but not least let's
actually combine these two to form one
schema I'm gonna say cons schema and I'm
gonna say joy object dot keys pass in
this object and this time we're going to
say personal info and that's going to be
equal to the schema we just created up
here so we have our personal info schema
so I'm just gonna copy this paste this
here and now if I go back to my array we
call it a preferences copy that
pass this here preferences schema
next let's actually call this so I'm
going to go down here I'm going to say
joy dot validate the first argument is
going to be the same as the last
tutorial so we're just going to say user
input second argument is the schema so
we're going to use the built in schema
that we made which consists of the two
different schemas that we created
separately last argument is going to be
the callback function so I'm just say
error result I'm gonna say if error
we're just gonna print out what the
error is else just print out the result
and the result is just gonna be the user
input so I'm just gonna save this that's
actually I just let me go in here save
this I'm gonna type a node app and you
can see that our data is validating so
the basic premise is if you're given a
complicated object break them up into
their individual schemas and then you
could combine them like so now I want to
talk about let's say that I want an
array of objects as opposed to an array
of strings so we're just going to go up
here we're going to change preferences
to reference array of objects and then
we have an example object here so this
is a very simplistic example we just
have a property of called example and it
has the value of a string so example 1 2
& 3 so we're just going to change this
to an array of objects let's go down
here and instead of specifying joy dot
string here because we're not looking
for strings anymore you can say joy dot
object dot keys and then we just build
our schema like we did before so in this
case we only have one property it's
called example and we're going to give
it the value of joy
string dot required so this is a very
simplistic example if you had a more
complicated object you would do the same
thing like we've been doing so I'm just
gonna save this and let's actually
execute this code see if it's working
node app and you can see that it
validates and we didn't get any errors
so that's basically how you can develop
a schema for a nested object and how we
can develop schemas for arrays and even
create our own custom schema objects for
those arrays
in this tutorial we're going to be
EJ s now what EJ s is is a template
language and that's going to allow us to
write more dynamic web pages so to get
started what we have here is a static
HTML file you can see that we have dummy
data here so when it says you searched
for stuff and we have search results of
dummy data now what we want to do is use
this HTML file as a template that we can
use for serving dynamic data so one way
to do that is if we go back to visual
studio code we could set the view of our
Express application and in order to do
that we would go here and we can say app
dot set is going to take in two
arguments we're going to specify the
view engine the second argument is going
to be the template that you want to use
so we're just going to say EJ s once we
set the view engine to EJ guess we're
gonna have to hit ctrl B and we're going
to have to create a folder called views
and this is gonna store our ejs
templates so I'm just gonna go down here
right click new folder and we're gonna
call this views now Express is going to
automatically know that our templates
are located in the views folder because
that's the default folder that it looks
for so now if I create my views folder
if I right click new file and instead of
saying index.html I specify index dot
ejs so now that I have my index ejs file
I'm just going to go through my index
dot HTML I'm gonna copy all this and I'm
just gonna paste the code within my
index dot ejs so now I'm just gonna save
this I'm gonna go to app by j/s and what
we do with templates is that we've
rendered them to the user so I'm just
gonna hit ctrl B get rid of the package
explorer and instead of sending a static
file I'm just gonna
move this and now we're gonna say res
that render and then followed by the
name of the file that you want to render
index now you do not need to specify the
dot ejs on the side and that's because
we already told expressed that we are
using ejs as the template so now if I
was to save this just gonna hit ctrl C
node app head over to Chrome we're gonna
hit refresh and you can see that we get
the same exact output so what happened
here well when we rendered this index
the EGS file what's happening is the
server is going to look at this EGS file
for ejs code it's going to execute it
and then send back to the client an HTML
file so now let's actually send data to
send back to our EGS file so from here
I'm just going to give us a route
parameter I'm just gonna say user query
and here we're gonna pass in an object
and this is going to be the data that we
want to display within our index by eg
as template so now I'm just going to
give it a property first I'll say data
then I'll give it a property of user
query and then we're going to pass in
request dot params dot user query so now
if I save this I'm just going to hit
ctrl C just to exit out of our server
now we're going to go to our eg as file
we're going to go here to our template
and now from here we're gonna specify
less than % equal what this means is I
want you to output on to the HTML file
next what we're going to do is access
the data that we just passed in so how
do we do that well we gave it the
then we said dot user query afterwards
we end it with % and then that so now
this is going to look at our app Taj is
just gonna say okay I want to render the
index page and this is the data that I'm
receiving so we went to data dot user
query so now if I was to save this index
that ejs template let's start back the
server node app let's go to Chrome hit
refresh you can see that we get cannot
get forward slash and that's because we
added a route parameter so let's say the
user searched for books for example then
it says hey you search for books so
imagine if this was a real website and
we were on Amazon or Ebay you would do a
search so then on top of that web page
you would get hey you searched for books
you searched for pcs you search for
whatever so that means I could use this
EGS template for all the items within my
website so now let's actually add some
dummy data so if I go back to visual
studio code and what we're gonna do is
instead of having hard-coded stuff here
when the user types in we search for
books we're gonna display a bunch of
books so I'm just gonna go to apt is
we're gonna pass in more dummy data so
we have data user query we're gonna pass
in another thing and I'm just going to
give it a Enter key to make it fit on
one line and we're gonna pass in an
array and this is going to be search
results search results
passing away and we're just gonna say
book 1 book 2 and book 3 so now if I
save this go to my index site ejs file
instead of saying dummy data what we can
do is we could go to data because that's
the object that we're passing in we're
going to say search results and then
since it's an array we can access index
0 and this is going to give us our first
position and remember since we this is
an EJ s template we're going to have to
wrap this up within the following and
now if I was to save this let's cancel
off the server restart it up go to
Chrome hit refresh and you can see then
now we're dynamically populating the web
page so now let's head back to visuals
through yo code and what I want to do is
instead of just outputting data search
results that index 0 data that search
results index 1 what we can do is use a
for each loop so for example let's get
rid of all this and instead of that
we're gonna pass in less than % we're
going to get our array so what's our
array data that search results dot for
each we get our result and remember
we're going to end this with a % less
than and the reason why we don't have an
equal sign here is because we are not
out putting this onto the HTML file so
for example if I want to output this
equal sign if you don't want to output
it no equal sign
next within here what we're going to do
is we're going to display what we want
to output so now what we're going to do
is use less than % equal because we
actually want this to output to the HTML
file so I'm just gonna say oh I
result and let's close our Li tag so now
we have to end this so we're just going
to end it with % we're not going to use
the equal sign because we do not want to
output this to the user so now I'm Phi
well as they save this let me go down
here control see no app go to Chrome hit
refresh and you can see that our search
results gets dynamically added so if we
search for books and there was a million
books this code will work for a million
books if we searched for iPhones and
there was only three types of iPhones
this code would work for three iPhones
so now let's do an example involving
conditionals so we're just going to give
a simple if statement if the user is
logged in we want you to display this if
the user is not logged in then we're not
going to display anything extra so now
if I go back to visual studio code let's
write an if statement underneath our h1
tag so I'm just going to go here I'm
going to say this if data dot logged in
and this is going to be a boolean
containing true or false let's end this
here and now the meat of our if
statement is going to be the HTML output
that we want to do so now I'm just gonna
say h2 you are logged in as data dot
username and that sense line and then
let's close our h2 tag now we have the
our if statement so let's close our if
statement and all we're going to do is
just through the following ejs close our
if statement and remember we're not
using the equal sign because we're not
wanting to output this and we're not
using the equal sign up here because we
don't want to output this if statement
so now if I was to save our index ejs
file let's go to app that J s and we're
gonna pass in those properties that we
added through our index each of those
file so we passed in logged in and for
this example we're just going to set
true and the user name is going to be
this so I'm just gonna go to index that
EGS just to see if we matched up
properly otherwise we're gonna get an
error logged in user name here make sure
everything matches up let's save this
ctrl C node app head over to Chrome hit
refresh and you can see that since we
are logged in we're displaying our h2
tag you are logged in as so and so if we
set that to false our h2 tag wouldn't
appear so that's basically the ins and
outs of how you can use ejs within your
Express application
in this tutorial we're going to be
talking about what middleware is and how
we can create our own custom middleware
so middleware is basically the code that
gets executed between the user request
and the server itself now in the
previous tutorials we already used a
middleware and that middleware was
within the body parsing module so if you
take a look at our Express application
on line 5 we say app without use and
then as an argument we pass an a
function and this function is a
middleware function that when the user
makes a request this function will take
the users request and process it in this
case the body parser dot JSON function
checks to see if the user have sent any
JSON data processes it and then attaches
it to the request about body and then it
calls a function called Next to let the
server know that hey we're done
processing this request you can send
another request so to get started we're
just gonna go down here I'm going to say
app use and then we're gonna pass in our
own middleware function that's going to
get executed whenever the user makes a
request so this should be very familiar
we're gonna pass in the first parameter
is going to be the request object the
response and then the final parameter is
gonna be the next method so now we
already are familiar with the request
object and the response object so what
is this next method this next method
must be invoked whenever you create a
custom middleware so what the next
method is responsible for is the letter
express note that hey I'm finished
processing this request if you do not
call the next method what's going to end
up happening is you're gonna timeout the
server because it has no idea whether or
not you're finish processing the request
or not so right now I'm just gonna say
next and we're just going to call it and
to make things a little bit more
interesting let's actually go up here
and I am gonna print out the request dot
URL and the request dot method so now if
I was to save this let's actually
restart the server I'm just gonna hit
ctrl C node app I'm gonna go to Chrome
I'm gonna hit refresh now when I hit
refresh what I did was make a get
request to the server
so let's actually take a look at Visual
Studio code to see what happened and you
can see that our middleware is running
so we made a request it gives us the URL
it gives us the method of the request so
we made a get request when we hit
refresh and then we said next which let
express know that hey he's done
processing this and then it got to this
point where we just sent res dot said
middleware onto the user so that's why
you see that we got this now let's
change this up so instead of saying
forward slash because we gotta get route
there let's just make something up now
if I hit enter you can see cannot get
whatever this route is but that's okay
because we're not interested in that
we're only interested in the middleware
for this tutorial and you can see once
again that our middleware is running
fine so whenever there's a request made
from the user
this middleware function is going to get
executed and you can see that our route
was printed out and the type of request
was also printed out onto the console
now this is all fine and dandy but as we
have it right now whenever we use app
dot use and we have our middleware any
user request is going to get processed
by this middleware let's say that I only
want this middleware to execute when
certain route gets requested so right
here I'm just gonna go here and I'm just
gonna say example and this is gonna be
our route and now whenever we call this
example route it could be any type of
request that could be a get request post
request put delete doesn't matter
this metalware is going to execute but
if it doesn't match this example route
then it's not going to execute so let's
save this and I'm just gonna hit ctrl C
node app start this up again and now I'm
just gonna hit refresh go back to visual
studio code and you can see that our
middleware is not executing but if I go
up here type example go back to visual
studio code and you can see that our
middleware is executing just fine and
the last thing that you should note that
middleware functions can do is modify
the request object and the response
object so going back to our body parser
example it parses the users request and
searches for JSON and then attaches it
to the request dot body so to give a
trivial example I can say take the users
request and I can add a property called
banana and I could assign it the value
of banana and for the sake of simplicity
since we already have this route here
we're just going to get rid of all this
and within our get route we're just
gonna say console dot log request the
banana so let's end that with a
semicolon let's double check everything
and this looks good so I'm just gonna
save this and we're gonna restart the
server no gap we're
go to Chrome and we're going to hit our
route and there we go if we go back to
Visual Studio code you can see what's
going on here
we made a request to the server the
server did some processing the same
thing that body parts are did and then
adds to the request object in this case
we just added banana gave it a value of
banana and then here when we got the
request from our get route you can see
that we get the output of banana so
that's pretty much the ends and outs of
how you can create your own custom
middleware and how middleware works in
in general
in this tutorial we're going to be
talking about the Express router now
what the Express router allows us to do
is separate our routes into different
files this makes our code a lot more
manageable as opposed to just sticking
our routes within the app dot J's file
so to get started I'm just gonna hit
ctrl B to bring up our Explorer I'm
gonna create a new folder to store or
our routes so I'm just gonna right click
here new folder let's call it routes and
we're gonna create a new file called
people so this is where we're gonna
store or our people routes so I'm just
gonna hit ctrl B again and since we're
using the Express router we're obviously
going to need to include the Express
module so I'm just going to say Const
Express is equal to require Express next
we're going to call it X press dot
router which is a method that's going to
return to us a instance of the router so
we're just going to save that within a
variable so I'm just gonna say cons
route is equal to express dot router so
now that we have our router instance
what we can do is set up our route so we
already know how to do that so I could
say route that get and we're just going
to give it the path and we're gonna give
it the callback so the request object
the response and we're just going to say
res dot send forward slash being hit now
let's just create another route so I'm
just gonna copy this for our example and
I'm gonna call this example and let's
say example being hit now we're not done
yet so right now we have this route here
but how do we expose this route so that
our app dot J s file can access it well
in order to do that we're going to have
to use module dot exports
so I could go down here type module dot
exports and then we're just gonna export
this route that we created so now I'm
going to save this we're gonna head back
to our app J s file and now down here
we're gonna have to actually require the
people row so how do we do that well I'm
gonna create a variable called people
and we're just going to require the file
so I'm just gonna say dot forward slash
I'm going to go inside the routes folder
and then I'm going to include our people
file but we're not done yet
remember on line three we created an
Express application so now we need to
tell our Express application that we
want to use this people route so let's
go down here I'm gonna say app dot use
and we're gonna give it the base URL so
I'm just gonna say four slash people and
then we're gonna pass in the people
route as the second argument so I'm just
gonna pass in people so now if I was to
save this head over down here note app
let's go to Chrome and I type localhost
port 3000 and that's because we do not
have a base URL remember we gave it
people so this is our base URL for this
people's route so right now this forward
slash would be accessed if I just typed
people at the end of localhost so I'm
just gonna add that people and now you
can see our forward slash is being hit
and if I add another forward slash and
do example you can see our example route
is being hit so now what happens if you
want to add middleware to these routes
so I'm just gonna go back to visual
studio code I'm gonna go to our people
route and within here I could say route
by use and then pass in our function our
middleware function that we want to
execute so I could pass in my request
object my res and next and now I'm just
gonna say console dot log middleware
being used now when I use route that use
all we quest is going to go through this
middleware so remember to always call
next
if you're ever creating your own custom
middleware and now if I was to save this
let's hit control C node app we're gonna
go to Chrome hit refresh and you can see
that our middleware is being used here
now this middleware is only going to be
used within our people route if we had
another route here let's say instead of
people we had an animal route this
middleware is obviously not going to get
executed because this middleware is only
specified to work with our people row so
that's pretty much the ends and outs of
how you can use the Express router to
actually separate your routes from the
app dot J's file